[Music]
oh
Wanna Live
[Music]
what a ladwell today I'm joined by one
of the biggest leads to come on the
podcast both in size and Lair today's
guest is an ex all black who's had a
very eventful career moving around all
the New Zealand super franchises which
included two stints with both the blues
and the Crusaders and once with the
Hurricanes he also spent a short time in
France in Japan and now is living in
Malaysia coaching the mighty Borneo
Eagles it is of course the great man
himself big Brad Mika welcome mate
uh greetings from Malaysia from hot
Malaysia
thanks for having me on the party book
event right awesome to get you on and
you popped up in conversation with a one
LED fan Nigel Nelly the other day and a
few days later here we are ready to rip
in so I appreciate you jumping on so
quickly yeah now good shout out to all
tonight see you in December bro
but Malaysia how did you end up in
Malaysia and how was it in Malaysia
um I was uh I was picturing in um in
Melbourne and one of my good mates is
here new Kumar who who uh you know very
well Jimmy and uh yeah they're looking
they're looking for a director of rugby
here and I was sort of thinking hey they
play rugby over there but um I was I was
up for the challenge so I come in I
think into 2015.
and uh sort of been here ever since
really
but it's uh it's good to see Jimmy you
got uh I know you've been here for a few
tournaments and it's good to see your
your uh your billboard up up around the
club
no way that's still hanging down Kuma
would have taken that down a long time
ago but have you found you're obviously
loving it over there you've been there
for what's that like eight years now so
obviously loving it yeah no it's been
good it's had its challenges
um but you know it formed a
you know really good uh culture at this
club at the state and uh some some good
uh players both woman and and Men uh put
a good a really good relationship with
my family was over here
you know really got into uh
uh with the whip of things here in in
Malaysia
um but uh yeah I think sort of coming
towards the end of my contract now so
family school back in New Zealand and uh
uh so just you know weighing up things
what's what's what's the next plan sure
how long have the family been back oh
they've been they've been back uh for a
while now yeah my kids are uh it's at
school in in Auckland so she's a bit
tough sort of coming over back and forth
and uh you know I'm sort of missed the
Old Camp or the odd game on the on the
weekend so yeah I sort of this this
year's been different I've been going
back and forth so it's pretty much just
coming for tournaments and then and then
shooting back so
hasn't been too big yeah and but
obviously covert were you
um separate there with the family back
in New Zealand you and Malaysia during
that time
no I I was lucky enough to when covert
first hit
uh I was stuck here for a bit and then
they had some fights going up I think
there was uh can't come in water I think
it was luggage flights or whatever float
it was and I happened to jump on one so
I got back home so then I was back home
for a couple of years which was good and
then with sort of opened up and then the
old uh boss ring back and said oh yeah
it's time to come back man I'm quite
loving it over here
so you see the contract's going to end
what what are you what are you thinking
at the end of this oh I'm not sure
um
you know
trying to see what the purchases at the
moment but you know in goal is trying to
get to where you guys are so what that
process looks like that I'm not sure but
yeah I think first things first want to
get back home close to my family and uh
just to see what happens after that so
coaching's the big drive you want to get
as far as you can in the coaching game
yeah I
I enjoyed it um yeah you know just the
strategy stuff
um looking at different teams and what
they're doing trying to suss out what
the common Trends are I love it
and just trying to apply it you know to
to my players and just getting you know
that that switch where where they get it
to it's yeah you know you get a good
feeling at it were you like that as a
player
um yeah like
I really love the attack and uh I mean
being a Ford and and um you know
sitting in with with the attack groups I
I really enjoyed the the different
methods that used to do back in the day
and I found you know
I was going towards the end of my career
I was thinking oh man wouldn't mind
being a coaching sorta you know
trying to be in that space and and just
to see what what I could at because you
were by all accounts you were a 10 from
a young age all the way up till sort of
like what year 11 or year 12 or
something so you've always had that Mind
of a of a first five yeah um it was
funny enough why yeah growing up I was
probably the tallest uh or the biggest
fish I've been around surely but maybe
and I sort of come through the great
counties 15.
um I was playing second 15 at Dela cell
and full form and then moved to St
Peters at football
and then uh I remember the coach saying
oh
if you want to go further in your rugby
you're gonna have to go to the engine
room
so yeah wouldn't turn yeah 11 I uh I
moved to the forts so how big were you
because like my image of you even from
like the age of five would be just a
massive guy just running through
everyone far too big for everyone else
trying to tackle yeah were you like that
but
but man it was I loved it playing in The
Backs like playing age grade my dad used
to be in my coaching uh man it was
because you uh could see that place but
at the same time you had twice so you
could have the running game as well yeah
uh no I really really enjoyed it until
we went to the engine we went and
started getting our back is this what
it's like
did you have much of a kicking game or
distribution game as a 10. yeah I quite
like uh the kicking game yeah yeah good
I really enjoyed it the old wipers
big right foot yeah which was good uh
you know like I said I really enjoyed it
uh but that sort of come to to an end
when I when I got that cool but it was
good though because I carried on the
skills that I had as a back into the
Fords which sort of suited my game a bit
not so much at luck but at eight later
later on in in my career so no I really
enjoyed it and I'm pretty Keen to hear a
little bit more about like your earlier
earlier days before you got into rugby
what was your sort of childhood like
what was your upbringing like and your
parents where were your parents from
because obviously genetic pool to create
the main mountain like yeah
yeah they they migrated to uh New
Zealand uh you know just so my sister
and I could have a a better life but um
I was I was grateful like we didn't have
much growing up my father worked two
jobs but
man uh my childhood uh
uh was was really enjoyable I mean you
know as you know back then there was no
gadgets there were no computers and and
laptops so
in the morning you get up do the chores
that you had to do and then straight out
the door straight on the street so I had
a group of mates that uh were in the
neighborhood and we used to get together
jump on the bikes go down to the creek
um we used to get those uh you know
their plastic things the Clippers at the
end of the bread oh yeah yeah those onto
the the spokes four wheel cool
now it was good man it was real
enjoyable and um I had a good mate that
lived next door
and uh all I remember when I was young
that his mom made some mean Feats so we
used to go out the whole day
sometimes it was it was there was no
food at home and looking a couple of
slices of bread squeeze the tomato sauce
that was good enough but there were
times we used to get a I think his name
was Christmas
you've got some good toys there
really enjoyed my um my childhood
nah yeah did you say how to travel like
you spoke about just putting um bread
tags on your spokes but was that about
as far down the trouble line you went
yeah I was um you know I was I was well
disciplined from old men
um yeah it was at a young age he he put
me into a lot of sports and um like my
family my both my friends were squash
players so I got into a bit of squash
um played a bit of soccer
uh cricket some other sports I carried
on going uh through school
um it was one sport that uh I didn't
like what she was swimming it took me to
swimming too and I used to think oh you
know why is it taking me to do all these
Sports and um I remember getting a
swimming I didn't know how to swim
and uh I thought it was swimming classes
but it wasn't it was like a club night
and then uh
so my dad will take me and then he'll
say oh yeah put these on there was a
Speedos I don't know what speed is what
it is
Arenas oh but it's tight [__] jump in
the pool
so jump in the pool and uh
well we used to do 50 meters or 25
meters or whatever it was and he used to
come I used to come last quite far out
the first one was the biggest
and used to be right at the back like I
was the the stroke in my my head will go
left and right
and the guys that are swimming games
were hit down a couple of Strokes brief
a couple of Strokes so
I used to I used to hate it but um I
remember when I finished when I finished
the race I'd look up and the guys that
was racing against were half changed and
look at my dad my dad was getting uh
well done son as long as you uh finish
the race
but I didn't quite I didn't quite
understand what uh what my dad was
trying to do back then but um because I
also played leak oh yeah and again I was
I was the biggest boy there and my
parents and parents uh parents used to
complain said oh are you sure he's eight
years old he's big yeah then so my
parents had to carry around that
a birth certificate every everywhere we
went oh that's right yeah it was like a
you know I was I used to fix the pickles
oh man man just starting to get tired I
don't know what what my dad was trying
to do but as I got older I sort of
understood what my dad was was trying to
do with me
and I think first was he was trying to
throw me out there to see what sport
um then I I wanted to pursue as I got
older or with a sport was for me and
then second was discipline
just keep me on the street and narrow it
was you know what was it like being in
Timber environment what was it like
being in a single Sport and then lastly
it sort of taught me uh about working
hard like work ethic like when I first
started I was a bit raw at some of those
sports but
I was competitive and I and I wanted to
get better at it and I knew
um that the only way to get better was
by putting the the working so
I used to go out there and get a choking
put a circle on the fence get some rips
in in the passing and rub the chalk off
before my dad saw it but
yeah when I look back at it now I mean
my my dad's second language was English
but you know when I looked back in the
house you know he's actually quite smart
but uh not really really grateful for
for what did for me yes that's so cool
so how did you end up in rugby and and
not swimmer oh so yeah As I Grew Older I
sort of um
I sort of leaned towards rugby I ended
up moving from League
and then went to the manurewa club
played Juniors there and then moved to
otahu
and then sort of didn't look back ever
since then we'd been through school and
then just carried on from there because
it was from memory I picked up by
Auckland at a pretty young age weren't
you yeah yeah
um I think it was my my last year of
schools hit seven four right let's go
um pivac was uh was the coach for
Auckland and he was he was pretty Keen
to sign me on
so I played one game for for the MPC
team
um shoot skid well let's go well let's
go and then all right because because at
that time when Rick rip rugby was on um
first 15 had finished so
I was either playing under 21s or beef
or development and again man I was I was
just a boy man but I was scared it was
good experience though how big were you
at this point
um yeah it was still pretty cool like
probably the same size as as the guys
that they had in the in the team but you
could tell that I had a a sort of I
wasn't filled out like you know it
wasn't much like everyone else yeah and
sort of had a baby face but man
it was it was it was a good ride though
good journey yeah good journey with us
and because you had been playing 10 up
until like two years earlier must have
been a real intimidating transition to
then go into professional footy in the
Ford pack and that sort of older school
era yeah like
I sort of it was all right playing the
cruise 15. yeah 11 and then yeah 12. it
was it was good because I sort of came
through the eighth grades like New
Zealand 16s back then was New Zealand
16s secondary schools in 19th so when
when it came to uh when I when I fully
signed with uh the MPC team it was like
it was different level like all these
guys were all grown men and like you
said it was old school so back then we
learned very fast I remember walking
into the change room it was it was me
and Ali Williams our first time walking
in then
I sort of heard what was you know that
hierarchy about you know the backseat
senior players and stuff like that
so we walked in and um there was a few
guys that were out on the field and
there were some that were still lifting
and changing
and I looked at earlier you know Ali
probably character confidentness that's
right my mate walks around puts his bag
on the chair
and then he uh hits off to the to the
loot
and I was I was a bit weary so I looked
I looked the head and straight ahead was
the the shower so I'd be like straight
for the shelves I pulled my back down
sat in there and started putting my
boots on
and then two seconds later here this big
bang and I I came out of the shower and
I looked and it was Ali's back all over
the floor like someone had brought all
over I came out and all I heard was
like I said it was like man you look
real fast back in back in these days
like well those senior players you had
to earn their respect you know sort of
to be in that environment and if you
were soft you know don't keep picking on
you the whole time do you think there's
a place for that like obviously it's
completely different now but did you
enjoy it like that or would you prefer
it being the real open sort of learning
there is now oh yeah I know I know it's
different now but man to be honest like
looking back in that looking back at it
now like man that was the way like I
enjoyed that I enjoyed that and it
really you know got you to knuckle down
and sort of work hard for your position
yeah but you know as as I was going out
of my career it was sort of uh I seen
your boys were sort of trying to go that
way but we could see it wasn't going
that way at all because some young boys
but when did you feel comfortable in the
environment how many how long did it
take you to feel like
um you could walk around comfortably oh
so that was 2001
um so still pretty young
um I think the second year because the
second year
I I went straight into Super 12. so yeah
that was with the Crusaders so then
again when I got to that environment it
was sort of similar but more
it was it was a bit different like that
old school way was sort of sort of
moving out slowly
or or was either that or the the
Crusaders did it differently but
um man it was still a good time
um I think 2002 towards the end of that
2003 then we were sort of knew where you
were what you uh your sport and what to
do and what not to do so yeah so how did
you end up in the Crusaders because you
obviously played what two years of NPC
call up from the Crusaders yes but so
that same year 2002 I was
with the 21 New Zealand twenty ones then
um Colin Cooper was the coach yeah
they must uh
I think we were the draft names were in
the draft so if that remember back then
was oh the old joke
yeah Facebook is still like 25 so they
will say whoever was out of the 25 got
chucked in a pool yeah so that yeah I I
didn't I wasn't even thinking about
super 12 to be honest I was still trying
to get my my head around NPC but I got a
call from uh
I think it was Darren Shen Shandy that
was managed at the time and said oh look
they're enchant here
uh congratulations you're on the
Crusader Squad and man I thought it was
hey you got the wrong number yeah and he
goes oh you expected to come tomorrow
God you'll find a book so and then when
he mentioned uh Coop's name I said oh
shucks so yeah went from two years there
they went straight into the Crusaders
which was a different environment to to
Auckland yeah and how was that
environment oh it was awesome man
um I really enjoyed today it was like
you had
Marshall
Jaco Maxwell Maxwell was an interesting
character it was the man did things
differently but man he could perform hey
when it comes to to games but no yeah
really really uh got the experience of
um
of that that level and there was man it
was totally different to NPC so it was
normally you know we'll normally oh I
was at the back of the back of the class
trying to learn I remember we had
testing we had testing and um
um I didn't know any anyone at the time
and I was again
oh I'll stick with the props this was 3K
when the testing was 3K so yeah you're
not doing the 3K I came second to last
Reuben Thorne was was behind me but
first second and third was the whole
front row Emmett Somerville
you wouldn't see that in Auckland
or even Thorne I wouldn't have expected
him to be last oh you know Ruth he was
um it may have not have been good at the
testing but man when it comes to the
game he was everywhere yeah it was
everywhere and I heard you uh named into
the official Crusaders chub Club what
was that one yeah
man
um yeah so
the crusaders had a chop Club so chop
Club was was for players that had skin
folds over over then over the normal
yeah so it had to do extra work so you
know you get skinnies done every month
or every three weeks um uh put on a a
training program separate to the cheaper
to the team so I think there was about I
don't know about five of us so
I remember uh
so the night before the game our first
game in uh
I was in my room it was about 10 o'clock
and then I get it took some uh tips from
flenny Corey Flynn so me and Flynn went
down to the Crusades at the same time so
we're pretty close and he goes on
a mix has got a ticks from uh moves he
said if you're Keen to go to uh
McDonald's
hey got a game tomorrow yes like
oh my the interviewers mate that's all
okay so he jumped in the car
we went to the drive through got our
macca's had a feed and then um
I remember we was getting uh hey
if you get caught or someone meets
McDonald's didn't even mention my name
okay
so anyway we we uh you know that on the
day of the game you weigh in before the
game oh yeah with the weigh in and I was
like three kgs three three kgs up and
the spinner goes oh why don't mix you
must be fully hydrated I was here and uh
three liters three liters
from that game on that that year we went
um we went unbeated that whole year and
we we we were Champions and had the
quotation you know musk is uh the key
was Mecca's bruh keep the tradition
[Laughter]
oh true so that year you went fully
undefeated that must have been a pretty
unreal
um experience for you yeah it was good I
mean like I said you know been my first
time in in that Arena and
just experiencing
um and playing alongside all those big
names like man you you know you learn a
lot like training was competitive
was our coach he was competitive two-way
he jumped into the com games so
man it was a good environment to be in
and um man it was like I I learned a lot
from from that first year and what was
your um first Camp experience like
um we had a camping um where is it oh
whatever it is so we had Camp there and
then um
so we checked in
and we had a uh check my room list first
time and I looked and it was Reuben
Thorne
so it was again I was nervously scared
and then it was uh looked at me and said
come on big fella so started walking
towards the room and opened our room and
uh there was only one king-sized bit and
then one little couch on the on the side
it was like a it's like a single culture
and uh he looked at me I was like oh no
oh oh I'll sleep on the couch
was there
so I know I ended up finding it was a
fold out so which was all right and then
man
like just lying there
like you know Roots he's a quiet man
doesn't really say much and I said you
know
looking at the world I don't know what
to say it was news
like he'll ask me a question oh do you
like Motorsport
yeah nah according to it I don't know
what Motorsports he put the Motorsport
on and he was watching it watching us
then
it was I think it was about 8 30. you
guys oh good father that's me mate sleep
time you turn off all the lights
but I did not try it as well bro I was
trying to get a sleep man I was looking
at I couldn't get to sleep three hours
man I was looking at the horse man but
yeah it was like it sort of taught me
like you know even though you're shy and
that I mean being a coach now it's that
connection there you know it's important
whether you know whatever Walk of Life
you come from but being in their team
environment is important to sort of
connect there and I was hoping you know
he was Captain I was hoping he will
connect but he's a quiet man that's so
funny I feel like everyone has one of
those stories when they're in like the
first time with someone who they're like
intimidated by all Starstruck by and
just doing the things that they wouldn't
usually do just yeah exactly
but that's that's correct but that year
was obviously like a successful year on
the field you become an all black like
instantly it's all been a massive ride
ride for you there and like straight to
the top how do you feel
um or how'd you find out becoming an
all-back
um
I remember I think it was the end of NPC
I don't know if I know it was the
breakup party so we were
we were heading towards waiheke
um so this there was a I mentioned there
where we had a end of year party so
we went over
and I think the announcement was on TV
but we didn't have a TV there was a
radio oh yeah
so party started and then
all the music went off
and uh they turned out the radio to wait
for the announcement and um
I don't know there was a slight delay so
they're about to name the team that was
with ads on the radio and then friendly
text me you guys oh congrats brother
we're making the ABS
it doesn't even come on the radio yet
and then my phone started going off
started going off saying Congress I was
going oh shots as opposed to looking
around the other boys everyone was like
inside
a win around the Marquee and I rang up
the old man and I said oh
hey is the list come out oh man congrats
son uh you did it so I was a bit
emotional but I knew
I couldn't I couldn't cry if I had to
come back around the Marquee in front of
the boys so I'd come I'd come around and
then um
quickly jumping up and down but waited
for the announcement announcement went
and then the party started but as the
party started I think it was me and
Keith because his kids that was the
first time keep me alone who um made the
squad too we ended up smoke bombing
jumped back on the on the um
on the fury and went back home
I remember coming back um home and uh I
wanted to see the my old men
and uh my mate was in tears day and he's
gonna all right see that's
that's what I was trying to get get you
to since you were young
and uh he saw the joked around he goes
oh it must have been the swimming
[Laughter]
oh that's so cool did you expect to make
it or did you have any sort of thought
that you were in the frame
yeah I sort of
sort of like back then like like it is
now like you wouldn't get any feedback
from the coaching staff or anything it
was like old school you just wait for
the announcement so
I was just going by the paper like it
was always in the frame there was either
uh I can't remember I knew it was Mark
Robinson Ali Felipe oh yeah and then me
and you know they're always bounce
between those names so
that that was that was probably the only
thing that that we could go on back then
but I sort of had a feeling that I had a
chance but then you know you sort of get
there feeling weird oh I'm gonna be
bummed out I'm too excited if I don't
yeah
you know just waited like the rest yeah
right that's so cool that's such a cool
story and what do you remember about
your day boo
um so we played England and uh I
remember coming on second half
remembered Johnson
so before the game he was he was having
a go at me and Ali
in the papers saying oh look at these
young kids coming on the scene
don't know what it is it's like at this
level I'm gonna eat you for lunch or
something like that something along
those lines I remember coming on and um
it was a rhino you know he was mocking
me in with elbow and um
we made the call but it was it was that
one it's not when you jump in the air
where you sort of fake it then put your
hands up in the pool come straight yeah
so I did that got the ball and he didn't
even compete he just stood there with
his hands on the subscribers what the
hell is that jump you little punk
so that was my first experience man just
running around
like you couldn't we played a click on
him you could you couldn't hear anything
but he couldn't even hear the line I'll
cause anything but
because being young and it was your
first time man like you were just
running to every rock yeah just trying
to get close to the boy yeah and did you
feel comfortable in that environment did
you feel like yeah you belonged there I
guess for me I was I was still like um
I sort of used to know I was sort of
still learning yeah you know I I thought
and wasn't mature I guess enough to
understand really you know the the hype
of that level
um even though I
um I learned a lot there and was
grateful in that level but it was like
man you just followed the senior guys
around you know it was it was just told
and you know try to express yourself
what you can
try contribute but being young you know
and you're still a bit timid you know
you're still hesitant so
yeah sort of Eastern and no yeah so like
you look at your career you only ended
up with three caps so what do you reckon
um sort of stopped you from having more
so so that was 2002 and then 2003 Super
uh Super Rugby
I couldn't hit any four
in the in the second year you got
injured and then just just didn't get
much game time in their second year
so
and then
that was 2003 then 2004 I had a good
year I knuckled down I really wanted to
get back in there
I knuckled down
um I had a good a really good super
Super Rugby year and and I remember at
the end at the end of it
um before the trials I've got a call
from Ted
and Ted was going oh mix
um
you've heard a you're one of the
standouts in in the tournament this year
in in the rocking position
but we're sort of going a different way
so rugby started revolving around then
so he's going I said what do you mean it
goes oh we're gone from the
the ball carrying lock in the Rhino
winner to two lineup winners so that
sort of mold
so he sort of said oh look how about if
you change to Lucy number eight
and I was thinking I was looking back
then I was going what are my chances
trying to get back in like you had
Rodgers
um Jerry
so I was going oh you know give it a go
I'll give it a go so
yeah so the next couple of years after
that I sort of uh went to eight
and then sort of came back in the frame
in 2006 and I got another call from Ted
so he goes hey look mix
uh you're on the good yeah good form now
and pushing pushing it pushing your name
forward to uh for selection so it's
pretty confident oh man that's good
um I still I still knew I was up against
you know some big names and then
I can't remember what game we had I
think was quarters or series and we lost
and then I ended up not making it and
then I got a call from tennis oh sorry
mix uh
because it had uh shag and I think
Smithy was there we've gone a new
Direction we've gone off uh such and
such place
but I was trying to push your name back
you know
just keep keep at your trade and uh
ended up hanging up and waiting
your head Coachman you get the overall
sales but
that was the last time bro that was the
last time so man it was like you know
like what they say when you make the ABS
is good but the hardest thing is trying
to stay in there yeah that's the biggest
thing
especially if you lose a bit of form or
you get injured you know in New Zealand
as you know that you're guaranteed
there's someone that's going to step up
someone new or someone young that's
going to take your place so
man
it was yeah it was a good experience
what do you put the um form drop down to
obviously you moved back to the blues at
that time
um was there anything you did
differently or you do differently now
looking back at it yeah no I'm
look
I don't know what it was to be honest uh
to me like like they say you know second
year syndrome I don't even know what
that is but you know like everything I
did was normal you know it was still the
same but yeah I just couldn't just
couldn't get things ready and then
man I yeah just end up being on the
bench most of the time flash was playing
man yeah I just couldn't really
understand what was going on really and
throughout that whole time you're
speaking about that the All Blacks you
were you were jumping around clubs as
well weren't you you went from the back
to the blues and you went back to the
Crusaders and then the Hurricanes yeah
so yeah so I started with the Crusaders
and then uh
uh so Crusaders wanted me to stay in the
Canterbury yeah
um to find NPC and stay there but you
know home is home always wanted to to
play for Auckland so I went back in 2003
yeah stayed here 2003 2004 and then
and then new Sephora came into the
picture it wasn't he wasn't a big fan he
wasn't a big fan of me so when he sort
of came into the picture
My name got uh thrown into the pool so
then
uh DMZ picked me back up 2006 which we
won again
and then 2007
um that was funny too so 2006 NPC I got
MVP for Auckland
and still couldn't make the uh
so remember back then it wasn't the
contract wasn't
it wasn't a done deal so you had to have
a good NPC to make super yeah
so yeah thinking that year
um when I got MVP I thought oh man back
home again by then the names came out I
was saying oh man didn't make it again
so Coupes Coupes was a hurricane oh yeah
and and uh
I remember at the end of that year when
uh when I got to award and had to say a
speech at the end of my speech because
everyone was there the board everyone
needed my speech okay
and then I put the mic down anyone again
and it was half of the boys games yeah
yeah
so then I went to the hurricane 2007 and
then I thought to myself oh man like
you're not getting any younger it's
probably time to hit overseas so ended
up uh going to France at the end of
super so it was your relationship with
Colin Cooper that essentially got you
the contracts around the different clubs
with Crusaders and then back with the
Hurricanes yeah so first time Crusaders
um yeah it was coops in there in 2006
[Music]
a lot of time for him so you mentioned
going over to France and was this you'd
sort of given up on your all black dream
at this point
um and just thought you weren't gonna
crack it anymore there and try to have a
overseas experience yeah so decided
um to go to France I uh
I thought it was time you know yeah
trying to go around and see the wheel
see what what um or rugby is like on the
other side so starting with brief uh for
four years for four years and I remember
before leaving and I was having a word
with um Gary whidden
so Gary Whedon was uh he was aligned
with cast Castro
and he was going oh Mickey you sure you
want to get a brief uh you should come
to cast I said oh
we just had a
I haven't had a good experience with the
director rugby who's gone from cast to
brief oh yeah oh okay
I didn't think anything of it so I'll
still win over
and then yeah now it wasn't until I got
there and then
it was different French rugby was
different a like the environment was
different I remember opening the gym and
it was like it was like a garage
but
um
I I sort of come to learn real fast what
uh Gary was talking about like they had
a direct direct me there that was Manny
was controlling her like before I got
there uh sort of halfway through the
season but they'd really gone through
nine coaches and then I was like hey is
that normal yeah
they ended up yeah like playing there
and then
um the director of rugby
[Music]
it was like
uh because we've hooked up six foreign
real senior senior players and I
remember like we used to get one of that
uh at um when it comes to review review
time and Ben used to speak up Ben Cohen
used to speak up you know man
that's the wrong game plan you know we
should have done this so
we ended up stopping uh all the clips
that were meant to go through and the
coach goes on the field so we started
doing Fitness
it was tough eight it was tough and then
I remember
the director of rugby coming to me is
this look uh Brad uh
for this team uh I want you to uh I
don't want you to book Harry all I want
you to jump Scrub Blue Rocks
and you know knowing myself that's not
my game yeah I mean it is part of my
game but my strength is my carry yeah so
I'm sort of thinking oh but sure that
you know that's that's my strength
carries my strength I guess you do what
I see okay so
but I knew I was on good coin and like I
used to wake up every morning because I
stayed in a sort of farm area and I wake
up every morning looking out the windows
just reflecting out man
this used to be a sheep there I used to
talk to him every morning
am I in the right place or what am I
doing
but like it got to a point where
you know it wasn't about money it was it
was about you know location and you know
enjoying it so in the arena I posted and
it lasted about five months yeah not
liking it here bro could you find
somewhere else so
pretty good oh no no worries they ended
up finding something in Japan you had
entity.com
and then
yeah I went so I went from France went
straight to
um Japan and man placed the Bieber loved
it awesome was it hard getting out of
your uh French contract nah so and like
not like Japan where Japan if you want
to cut it you got to honor it you know
just the way the culture is but yeah
France it was like you can negotiate Hey
look
so I I played that oh look good family
um most of my family got you know issues
back home near to go back so they sort
of worked out a package so yeah I like
okay if you go only you can take this
thing you know you don't have to pay you
out so
um no it was quite easy sort of getting
out uh out of the French contract what
happened to the shape I think I buy some
machine
or hopefully we'll cross path sometime
soon Buddy
have you seen them since nah man like
you know when you get into this BC and
uh
the money's good but I'm not enjoying it
you know the money's gonna look after my
family but still not enjoying it but man
I went the other way man rather enjoy
life than uh then try you know hang
around for for the money yeah and what
was the money like in Japan that's
generally pretty good as well oh it's
good man it was like
probably double what I was getting in
New Zealand yeah or maybe double and a
half I was getting in New Zealand which
was good and
but yeah like I said man I was like
I can
knuckle in and stay here but I tried man
I I could be honest and I said oh you
know I tried
to to be happy there but man it was just
like especially for us foreigners it was
man it was tough one thing was
sometimes a French sort of felt a bit
threatened that we were Outsiders that
we were there and they weren't that good
enough yeah
so they sort of made it
like they sort of made it hard as well
and then it was funny they were like
walking to Tangerine like back home like
you get the power AIDS and and
everything like that but I walk into oil
change room there was like two coffee
machines
so every time we come off off The
Paddock and the guys will go straight
into the coffee you know like how the
French love it yeah
but it was like yeah no uh it was it was
hard because when I left in the other
foreigners were going oh what are you
doing he's like now man I can't do it
um I'm moving to Japan so when I left I
think three weeks after that one by one
all the other foreign
and you mentioned you love Japan
um how'd you find the culture obviously
they're they're smaller race you would
have been an absolute giant over there
yeah no it was um man I loved I love the
I love my time there I was really
enjoyable
um we had some good foreigners then as
well we were taking division at the time
oh yeah we were taking the business at
the time trying to make toppley
so man just the experience the living
um how honest the the the people are I
mean about losing my wallet a couple of
times with cash going to the police
station and picking it up with cash in
it yeah
but um you know I really enjoyed it we
had um I think
Australian
coaching staff which was good I actually
got to my first when I was in Japan you
know as you as you know Jimmy all the
preseason stuff on the line right
foreign
in Japan the three years that I was
there and how are your knees at this
point because I know any issues with
something that sort of
um followed you throughout your whole
career how are your knees at this point
so my first two three is oh three years
but good it was fine it was no problem
it wasn't my third year where
I decided to go back home
uh panel was coaching in and he asked me
if I was Keen to come back to the blues
so
I remember we had a stolen season
we're about to start uh the top league
and I had just signed the contract with
the blues to come back the following
year
and then that Saturday we played and I
took my ACL
I did my ACL and I was like oh
it's a ring of pet and I said oh
I did my ACL so it looked like I'll be
out for the year so I come back or stay
here so you guys are now you know
they'll be we work that out what what
will happen when I'll be back so
I ended up going back going back uh back
to the blues done my time in Japan and
then
man when I come back it was like injury
after injury so I did my ACL did my
rehab and then come back I think around
four
of uh super 15 I think was there yeah so
before I had my my first game back uh I
had to play one game at a club so
I had my game at club and then in the
first I think first half
the knee was fine but I snapped my
achilles same leg Yeah uh no other
league other league yeah so man I was in
a dark place there I I was looking
forward to coming back and man went from
yeah ACL straight to the Oculus so
at least was a bit longer than uh the AC
house so pretty much missed that whole
year I saw it for two years and I think
I only played like five games yeah for
the blue
and then I knew then that you know I was
sort of that was sort of my time and
like uh I remember
uh because after that I had floating
bone chips in my knees bone spur so it
always better come in and then I
remember seeing Stu wash the surgeon and
you guys oh look at me
uh
uh what I can do for you is I can
I can repair your knee but
uh if you want to run around uh in the
next 10 years with your kids then you're
probably gonna have to uh
you know
let go of a footing so it was sort of a
high pool to swallow you know
you know it's been pretty much half of
your life you know playing footy and
traveling the world and but all sort of
like that's when I sort of thought oh
you know how can I stay in the game
how old were you at that point
uh I think about
28 I think yeah still pretty young yeah
yeah now from there I knew the knees
ain't gonna hold up anymore so
um got into coaching went through
Community level Grassroots level each
grade reps in Auckland and then
yeah ended up here and how hard was that
last few years of your career where you
were battling with those injuries what
what did that sort of look like for you
like mentally yeah it was it was tough
to be honest like
um you know like any injury like when
you're injured and
you know you want to get on the field
but you can't and then you know you're
sort of doing your own training away
from the team and you're always on the
physio table and stuff like that it's
like
even though you try to come back but you
know
your your injuries are not you know not
telling you that so man I was puppy it
was sort of but all I could do back then
was like just
I guess just to support the team and
sort of nurture the young ones that were
coming through I think the only value I
could give back then was that you know
rather than being a football everywhere
we went
and when you're told that news that you
you aren't going to be able to play
rugby again
um obviously it's a tough one but what
did you have did you have anything
planned life after rugby you had this
dream of staying in the game coaching
um
how did you how did you approach that
whole transition of life after rugby
yeah I thought
but so I wanted to do coaching
I would I sort of dabbled in uh teaching
I was doing this uh went into teaching
after uh before I became proof so all
right it sort of went on hold yeah and
then I was going to continue with that
but then I sort of wanted to stay in
rugby so I wanted to give coaching a a
go
um but remember back then it was it was
voluntary so you used to sort of start
from Grassroots level so I needed a job
and I remember jumping my my uncle had a
roofing company so I jumped on the roof
with him
right that was the hardest job I've ever
convenient but man from there from there
I got respect for the tradies they like
we were the first one on site before you
know before sunrise and then flipping
was our last to go and like I was still
coach coaching then come to coaching and
man you were spent like you had no
energy yeah and I was thinking oh man I
wonder how these treaties thought but
but even that was Hardee you know trying
to speak with my niece trying to go on
the beams and uh knuckle down the the
iron and stuff like that I was like
all right man is this for me bro but uh
now eventually uh I think I need I think
close to a year I was on the roof but
then still kept my coaching up and then
ended up going from there to Melbourne
coaching Melbourne University for a year
and then ended up coming in after that
and what did you miss about the game
once you once you hit lift it what'd you
miss about it
for me it was just like the camaraderie
with the you know your teammates
I mean just uh the friendships that you
had been in the team environment
uh you know going through the ups and
downs of the sport
you know just all that stuff you know
was man I was enjoyable
uh just you know being with your good
mates and
sharing good times and memories with
them why did they not miss
uh
didn't miss doing the skin Falls in
there
[Laughter]
didn't like recovery that's probably why
my knees went through good because man
recovery yeah like because because we
trained in the city if I could look back
now I probably would have done my
recovery better because
when it was like would finish training
and it was like five and going back out
South there was a group of us toyava
kaino yalamu and we used to quickly jump
in the cars try to beat traffic where's
everyone else jumping and do the
stretching and you know get the recovery
looking back at it now I was like man I
wonder why my knees are bung because you
know it wasn't just to put them in that
area
and then when you go over to Melbourne
you're catching the uni how'd you feel
going into that environment and being a
being a coach oh it's good
um oh I was lucky enough when when I
when I moved to Melbourne for that year
the the players
they were playing there
we all used to play in Auckland so
they're drifted and moved on to onto
Aussie so
I mean in terms of connection and
relationship you know I already had that
with those players so which made my job
a lot easier
but um no I really enjoyed it we we went
well that yeah
ended up making the final we lost the
final to um Harlequin to Greg McGrath
and all those guys
yeah it was no it was good experience
just the coach in in Australia and then
you take up Kuma's call to head over to
Malaysia and was that a hard decision to
move to Malaysia no like you know all my
life you know I'm always up for a
challenge and um one that you know I
know like if you sit in your comfort
zone you don't achieve anything so I was
going into the unknown and um at first I
think hey did they play rugby there but
when I got here you know it was it was a
real eye-opener you know like Grassroots
level and
and stuff like that which was good like
you know
I know like every other country where
you go to the country you can't really
bring
uh your country to it
um run away you sort of got to embrace
the culture first and then slowly drop
feed what you're what you've learned so
over here
um a lot of stuff we're doing back home
is what we're doing here which is good
and
you know some of these players that sort
of started uh sort of younger younger
age are now sort of seniors in in the
group here which is good
um I was fortunate enough to um to coach
the national team as well which was
another eye-opener and um I mean these
guys are not pros and we were in the
competition with Hong Kong Korea which
are all pros and um just thought you
know some guy's got to make it because
of work or they've got Muni and
so it wasn't going off three weeks uh
preparation and you know trying to get
uh preseason games trying to keep them
foot stronger so it was all a challenge
but you sort of learned to try and work
with it and try and make it work which
is which is what I enjoyed right
um no it's been an experience all right
some some good people the a ton family
that are that are here that that grew up
there's them as one of his older
brothers is the big boss here so
they've been good man they've looked
after me while I've been here in my ears
so grateful for them too and how far are
Malaysia off
um you mentioned like not being any
professional setup
how do they go in those games against
the Hong Kong Etc of the world yeah so
when you're looking at say Korea so most
of the Korean players playing the uh the
top league in Japan and then you've got
the Hong Kong guys who are fully
professionals right like when we first
started off when we got into that that
division it was like it was tough man
you're looking at about 60 points oh
Trey
um but then yeah well it was it was
tough man like you try to go to the
the union and say look you know this way
forward is probably the way we should
try to go and but you know they have
their own reasons and and their own
things that they have to look after and
but it's something it's been tough when
I stood down I
um I came back here I was still here in
Borneo but took over oh yeah and uh
talking to him after he sort of had the
same experiences oh man I didn't know it
was like that and it's sort of you know
it's a big challenge but you know it's a
challenge there it's good to take on
because you learn even though you're not
winning games and stuff but you're still
learning
you're still learning stuff of you know
how to get better or how to how to try
get the best out of the player
especially from here that are not
you know as good as as what we're used
to back home and stuff like that
so
man it is an experience would you have
any professional players or if there is
a talented player in Malaysia where do
they go to
become professional yeah so there's
um there's probably a couple of Pros
that have been here two girls one he
played in Japan for a while Yamaha oh
yeah uh and then he played in the mlr
I think this year for Chicago then you
had Markley Markley was that Rico
playing in Japan oh yeah those are
probably the only two
um that have played Pro but there is uh
I guess the the main sport sort of what
they're looking at here in Malaysia is
the seventh
um to be honest I don't think there's
really a pathway for 15th to be honest
because
like you got the likes of Hong Kong
career where you play and then the
winner of that goes to the next pool
and then you jump you go into a pool
with Oceania and then try to find uh the
team that will get the last spot in the
World Cup yeah so Hong Kong I think one
year they went all the way played Cook
Islands and then they ended up losing
against Canada oh yeah at the end yeah
so you're up against those sort of teams
in America
yeah it's interesting yeah interesting
so when how far what about the Malaysian
seven side how far off are they from you
know getting on the world circuit oh you
know again probably like wow there's
your best ones are probably Hong Kong
again yeah
um
yeah it's still pretty pretty uh a long
way right it's interesting eh like the
difference between the all the levels
like you said at the World Cup at the
moment and
um the difference between the top teams
and the bottom teams and then you go
right down to like the malaysias and
how far off they are but um yeah I think
it's like for them I think like if they
get a bit more exposure if they
under a professional program where they
get paid like you know how would what
it's like then you can see a difference
because there's some Talent here there's
some Talent they may not have size but
you can put on toys yeah they're quick
and they can understand the game uh you
know all the structures or the maps or
whatever you have but it's just that
that process of you know how can we make
them bigger stronger where can we send
them to get them better because and they
could make a difference but it's just
it's just the way things are you know
are things that things are done here in
Malaysia yeah well they've had the right
coach
um with them for the past few years so
I'm sure they're learning heaps
as always in this podcast we've gone to
our Instagram full-some questions and
we've had plenty coming
um for the great man so we'll try and
rip through a few of these
um before the end first question is
what's the best try you've ever scored
this must have been good
yeah
please drive it was good
um I think I was uh it might have been
Wellington against Wellington and I was
talking to my mate today but
yeah that was Kate Wellington and um
ended up being at the Rock and you know
that remember that rule before that rule
came in you could be in front of the
ball and take the ball from behind oh
yeah yeah yeah so I remember I had my
hand on it and um
I remember Luke Andrews moving to the
Rock position and he was a hole there so
I picked it up and I went through and
when I looked there was times Thomas was
the last line of defense and I was like
Tom's a good Defender and you know he's
he's he's a smart he's a smart guy so
I can't believe what I did but I had the
ball in one hand I looked the other way
and my move went and my feet started
moving
lucky enough times went the other way
and I got past them and they ended up
scoring then uh
that's that's probably the only try I
remember
thanks Tom love you
oh one of the great tries one-on-one
with Tommy Ellison or not nearly make
him look like a fool like that
okay next question is winning the
Gallaher shield for otahuhu greater than
winning Super Rugby uh to be honest yeah
it was
um I mean I mean Super Rugby or special
yeah uh winning the trophies but
I mean that would have been one of the
highlights of my career was was was my
club the red and blacks I mean
man we we won that in uh 2000 with uh
with the late uh
Jeff Mooney he's passed away but man I
remember because you know from school
being in Auckland like sort of to make
NPC was like you sort of had to move to
the city clubs to sort of get recognized
yeah
and like we had some good talent out
South Auckland and um so for everybody
we had already Kevin
um so we sort of we sort of thought I
remember
I mean I think it's kivio saying that
you know if
like we didn't have the flash Club rooms
I mean at night we had to train under
one lamp because all the other three
different work uh the showers didn't
work that well but I remember I think it
was Kevin was saying that if we if we
could make it out of South Auckland
uh we could make it anywhere in the
world and we sort of stuck by that and
we we we we we we stayed um ourselves
true to uh to edu and we're fortunate
enough to to win The Gallows shield and
uh I didn't think I lose come close to
winning that again oh the Glory Days oh
what a win okay next one how does he
think the Malaysian national team would
go against the New Zealand under 85 kg
team
um
was that
tit oh I'm not sure
no kid ring me up and asked me if how
the 85s will go against uh
the national teammates
oh I don't know I don't know but
I don't know if he will be on the ground
um
it should be a good game to be honest
Jimmy if um
the national team medical at the 1985 so
I mean I guess there's some big boys
here yeah I'm pretty sure yeah now it'll
be a good game okay interesting yeah
okay
okay next one best player you played
with
uh
best player I played with was probably
um
I think Chris Jack oh yeah
um when I started off um man he he
really took me under his wingy and um he
taught me everything
oh you know what what to expect
especially in that you know being a
crusader in in that environment like it
was real open and real support of um
and man it helped me on the on the field
too like sometimes I forget to run out
and then you know it was it wasn't that
one to sort of punish you it was always
like
you know up your ass trying to say hey
look don't worry about it next one man
it was real that's that's one thing that
I'll I'll always remember
and man he was he was also men at his in
his in his prime man he was Unstoppable
it was you know he had to carry he was
good at line out strong scrimatur so
yeah no probably jacket Chris Jack like
that that's a throwback good one okay
hardest part of being a professional
rugby player
um
I think the hardest part being a
professional was um
I guess uh injuries really
um I mean or like you know you could be
you could have a good season and then it
could be stop by by injury
um lost the form I think that's that's
probably the biggest one like it's yeah
it's all about trying to get that
balance because you can go to a dark
place when uh when you're injured but
when you're riding High man it's it's
you ride the weight bro
the true roller coaster right yeah
okay uh next one what was your favorite
Super Rugby environment to be involved
with hurricanes Crusaders or Blues
uh I probably didn't have a favorite
like I really like all of them and
they're the good thing about it was it
was different so I learned different
things from different environments that
I could put in my game
both mentally and physically but man I I
really enjoyed um
yeah I really enjoyed all the
environments that that I did go to and
yeah that's hard to hard to pick that
one but yeah Crusaders right up there
what was the differences between the
three I guess like say Crusaders were
like
um
like you know how they had the theming
and net like what teams are doing for
the last 16 years yeah we were doing it
back then okay and uh for crusaders and
like it was new to us but it was
engaging yeah I see now that you know
race was the man out there but like we
were doing it back then and like when I
go to the blues there was nothing like
that there was nothing to do with
theming or anything like that so
I guess
um
the Crusaders always had that AJ and um
like the way they did pre-season was all
different you know like the old school
on the line you know back and forth like
we'd do kayaking mountain biking
and I think things you could see
different skills out of those sports
that we could bring into rugby which was
like real unique
um but you know I think that was their
um the blues was good like you know had
all my mates then was not the old school
way but you know it was like sort of
family as well like you're in for your
brother we're all in so and then
hurricanes was sort of similar to
to to the blues environment
um just different blokes real but
everywhere man was good was an enjoyable
time and all three franchise so cool to
get the inside of all three okay last
question best piece of advice from a for
a water lad listener
um
probably
uh be yourself your real self and and
know your value and your worth
um I mean I say that like sometimes it
being yourself becomes an illusion where
you've got to act differently or you've
got to act in a certain way that you
know people could see you at and that's
I see that as it sort of limits your
growth and sort of you know limits your
potential but to come to become
something great
and I mean guess if we're talking about
being yourself and vulnerability
sometimes people think you know how it's
like where you don't have the confidence
you start trying to be something that
someone that you're not
and then
you know you I think
um being vulnerable is a powerful tool
and
being vulnerable you can be yourself
and you can add value in it and it's
inspiring to to many people whether it's
support or your workplace so
yeah I guess be yourself be your real
self and know your value in your work
right I love it what a way to finish one
of the great podcasts um honestly really
appreciate you coming on a big fan of
yours growing out watching you on the TV
and to hear that you listen to what
alert and follow follow been following
this podcast Journey um pretty humbling
for me to hear and how quick you were to
jump on and go through your story um
it's been awesome to have you on and go
through it and
um yeah have a yarn awesome I appreciate
it thanks for the opportunity uh Jimmy
all right and good luck for the coaching
journey and what's next um no doubt
there'll be a few teams I'm looking to
hit you up after this and hopefully CEO
Becky and the New Zealand Shores
coaching
um some of the next New Zealand talent
coming through
cheers